und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Anne Gellinek
[Musik]
es ist nur scheinbar eine gute Nachricht
dass der Staat in den nächsten Jahren
mehr Steuern einnimmt als ursprünglich
erwartet und das trotz hoher
Energiepreise und Inflation bei
genauerem Hinsehen steigen die
Steuereinnahmen nämlich genau deswegen
denn wenn waren teurer werden dann
steigen auch die Steuern die oben drauf
kommen der Staat ist also ein
Krisengewinnler Finanzminister Lindner
wiegelt ab die prognostizierten
Mehreinnahmen seien nur optisch groß in
Wirklichkeit sei das Geld längst
verplant Frank Buchwald berichtet aus
Berlin
mehr Geld in der Steuerkasse trotz
Wirtschafts- und Energiekrise klingt gut
ist aber trügerisch sagt Christian
Lindner Spielräume für weitere Ausgaben
bestimmten nicht
wir dürfen uns von den jetzt
prognostizierten Einnahmen nicht
täuschen lassen die Ergebnisse der
Steuerschätzung sind ebenso wie die
Erwartungen zur gesamtwirtschaftlichen
Entwicklung dieses Mal von höchster
Unsicherheit gekennzeichnet drei Tage
haben die Steuerschätzer gerechnet bis
2026 sagen sie für Bund Länder und
Gemeinden Mehreinnahmen in Höhe von
126,4 Milliarden Euro voraus im
laufenden Jahr kommen sie auf ein
Gesamtvolumen von
887,7 Milliarden das sind 1,7 Milliarden
weniger als bei der letzten Schätzung im
Mai im kommenden Jahr sollen die
Steuereinnahmen auf
937,3 Milliarden klettern ein Plus von
8,9 Milliarden auch die Union mahnt zur
Besonnenheit wichtig ist jetzt dass man
einfach ehrlich und jahresbezogen
rechnet das heißt welche Mehreinnahmen
haben wir in der Kasse aus den deutlich
gestiegenen Steuereinnahmen welche
Einsparungen können wir leisten und dann
erst muss die Frage auf den Plan kommen
sind dann noch zusätzliche
Kreditaufnahmen erforderlich das wäre
solides Haushalten genau umgekehrt wie
ist der Finanzminister im Moment macht
Grund für die steigenden Steuereinnahmen
sind vor allem steigende Preise längst
nicht nur für Energie
inflationsgewinne die der Minister an
die Steuerzahler zurückgeben will wir
möchten nicht dass die Menschen höhere
Steuern zahlen weil sie auch
inflationsbedingt steigende Löhne haben
und dann in einen höheren Steuertarif
Rutschen der Staat darf nicht von
steigenden Löhnen profitieren die noch
nicht einmal einen
Kaufkraftverlust verhindern
Entlastungen die in der Steuerschätzung
bisher noch gar nicht berücksichtigt
sind die entlastungspakete die wir
zuletzt beschlossen haben sind mit einem
kalkuliert so dass die Steuern
Mehreinnahmen noch reduziert werden
müssen anhand der gesetzlichen
Neuregelungen bis zum Ende des Jahres
auch deshalb will der Minister an der
Schuldenbremse festhalten kritik kommt
von der Linkspartei wir durchleben als
Gesellschaft eine existenzielle Krise
für viele Menschen für das Handwerk für
kleine mittelständische Unternehmen und
es braucht jetzt natürlich gezielte
Investitionen um aus dieser Krise
rauszukommen das heißt die
Schuldenbremse muss endlich fallen
Milliarden neuer Schulden aber stecken
bereits in diversen Schattenhaushalten
das weiß auch der Minister und die
Schulden von heute sind die Steuern von
morgen erst recht in Zeiten steigender
Zinsen
und in Berlin begrüße ich jetzt Marcel
Fratscher den Präsidenten des Deutschen
Instituts für Wirtschaftsforschung guten
Abend die ganzen letzten Wochen und
Monate haben wir vom Kanzler und vom
Finanzminister gehört wir warten bis zur
Steuerschätzung und dann wissen wir wie
viel Spielraum die Regierung hat Frage
also ist jetzt Spielraum für Entlastung
und wie sollte die aussehen
der Staat nimmt zenitat sehr viel mehr
Geld ein das ist richtig aber er hat
natürlich auch das Teil dieses Geldes
schon verplant auch das ist natürlich
richtig 190 Milliarden Euro kosten die
vier entlastungspakete die die
Bundesregierung ja schon versprochen hat
als Entlastung aber gleichzeitig
realisieren wir eben auch dass diese
Gelder sehr ungleich ankommen Mensch mit
geringen Einkommen erleben individuell
eine viel höhere Inflation also wir
erleben eine zu höchst unsoziale
Inflation weil Menschen mit geringen
Einkommen vielmehr ihres monatlichen
Einkommens für Energie für Lebensmittel
für die Dinge aufbringen müssen die
besonders teuer geworden sind und der
Staat hat sehr stark geholfen es gibt
kaum ein Land in Europa das größere
Hilfspakete aufgelegt hat aber es kommt
eben zu wenig dort an wo es wirklich
besonders dringend ist also sprich bei
Menschen die wenig Einkommen haben die
verletzlich sind und von dieser Krise
besonders hart getroffen sind dazu passt
das heute ein Papier durchgesickert ist
nachdem die Bundesregierung
die Abschlagszahlung für Energie im
Dezember wegfallen zu lassen also der
Bund übernimmt sie quasi das wäre ja
dann auch so eine gießkannenaktion was
müsste denn stattdessen passieren aus
ihrer Sicht
die Politik muss zielgenauer Menschen
mit mittleren und geringen Einkommen
Lasten zwei Maßnahmen werden sinnvoll
einmal dass man Einmalzahlungen so wie
man das in der corona-pandemie
beispielsweise in der Pflege gemacht hat
dass man weiß es gibt hier bestimmte
Sektoren bestimmte Menschen die sehr
wenig verdienen geringe Löhne haben vom
zum Beispiel den 3000 Euro steuerfreien
Einmalzahlungen die Unternehmen an ihre
Beschäftigten zahlen können in vielen
Fällen nicht profitieren eine
Kassiererin im Supermarkt oder jemand in
der im der Gebäudereinigung wird
wahrscheinlich nicht vom Arbeitgeber
3000 Euro bekommen und da wäre es
wichtig dass der Staat dort gezielt
genau Menschen mit wenig Einkommen
entlastet und das zweite wäre auch bei
der Grundsicherung nachzulegen das
Bürgergeld hat eine Erhöhung von 53 Euro
pro Kopf ab 1 Jan am nächsten Jahres pro
Jahr pro Monat aber auch das wird für
viele mit ganz wenig Einkommen nicht
ausreichen also es geht darum Menschen
mit geringen mittleren Einkommen mehr
dieses Kuchens zukommen zu lassen bisher
ist zu viel peggieskernprinzip entlastet
worden dazu kommt ja noch das
Finanzminister Lindner quasi zweigleisig
argumentiert einerseits sagt er so viel
Geld ist es gar nicht und es ist auch
schon verplant andererseits aber wir
haben genug Geld so viel Geld dass wir
die Schuldenbremse einhalten können
welches Argument überzeugt sie mehr
ehrlich gesagt keines der beiden
Argumente der Staat sollte nicht fragen
was ist die Schuldenbremse was erlaubt
sie sondern er sollte wirklich fragen
was ist jetzt notwendig um Unternehmen
zu stützen
Arbeitslosigkeit über
Unternehmensinsolvenzen zu verhindern
was brauchen Menschen vor allem
verletzliche Mensch mit wenig Einkommen
denn wenn der Staat jetzt nicht genug
hilft also sagt er will lieber sparen
oder keine neuen Schulden machen dann
ist der wirtschaftliche Schaden ja viel
größer das heißt auch die
wirtschaftliche Erholung wird schwächer
sein und der Staat wird dann auch in
drei oder fünf Jahren weniger
Steuereinnahmen haben also ich die
oberste Priorität meiner Ansicht nach
sollten jetzt kluge
Zukunftsinvestitionen sein in die
Menschen in die Stabilität der
Wirtschaft aber eben auch im Klimaschutz
und in andere
transformations-technologien damit die
wirtschaftliche Transformation gelingt
das ist zwar kurzfristig kostet eine
Menge Geld ist aber langfristig auch in
Bezug auf Schulden und Wohlstand die
beste Strategie um Schlimmeres in dieser
Krise zu verhindern also gegen die
Schuldenbremse Marcel Fratzscher war das
Präsident des Deutschen Instituts für
Wirtschaftsforschung herzlichen Dank und
schönen Abend nach Berlin dankeschön
und wir bleiben beim Thema nämlich wie
die rekordinflation eingedämmt werden
kann die Europäische Zentralbank
versucht es mit einer weiteren einer
dritten Leitzinserhöhung von 0,75
Prozentpunkten auf jetzt zwei Prozent
die Idee dahinter bei höheren Zinsen
wird das Sparen attraktiver Kredite
dagegen teurer das soll zu weniger
Konsum führen und das wiederum zum
Sinken der Preise soweit die Theorie
doch in der Praxis hat das erhebliche
Nebenwirkungen zum Beispiel in der
Bauindustrie Peter Theisen berichtet
diese Kräne sollten jetzt eigentlich auf
Baustellen stehen und Tonnen schwere
Lasten heben stattdessen Zwangspause auf
dem Firmenhof in der Baubranche ist die
Krise schon da explodierende Material
und Energiepreise sorgen für eine
stornierungswelle im Wohnungsbau
furchtbar ja wir leben ja davon zu bauen
und wir brauchen Projekte und es gibt
immer weniger Projekte ich habe da ganz
viele Sorge auch auch sozialpolitisch
die Politik hat sich ja zum Ziel gesetzt
dass wir 400.000 neue Wohnungen jährlich
bauen müssen unter den aktuellen
Bedingungen ist das
utopisch unwahrscheinlich dass es in
absehbarer Zeit besser wird denn auch
die Bauzinsen haben sich seit Anfang des
Jahres vervierfacht und sie werden wohl
weiter steigen heute hat die EZB den
Leitzins wieder deutlich um 0,75% Punkte
erhöht
unsere Geldpolitik zielt darauf ab die
Unterstützung der Nachfrage zu
reduzieren und dem Risiko vorzubeugen
dass sich die Inflationserwartungen
dauerhaft nach oben verschieben mit
diesem großen zinschritten sollte sie
weitermachen bis sie dann anfangen
nächsten Jahres in einem Bereich von 4%
liegt mit ihrem leitsitz und ich glaube
das ist mittlerweile notwendig um die
hohe Inflation wieder runter zu bekommen
im Kampf gegen die Inflation haben
sowohl die EZB als auch die
amerikanische Pferd die Leitzinsen seit
Jahresbeginn deutlich erhöht obwohl die
wirtschaftliche Ausgangslage kaum
unterschiedlicher sein könnte in den USA
haben wir eine Konjunktur die überhitzt
ist in den USA haben wir eine Notenbank
die versuchen muss die Wirtschaft
auszubremsen und die Situation haben wir
in Europa nicht hier ist die EZB
wirklich besorgt um ihre Glaubwürdigkeit
hier geht es der EZB darum um nachhaltig
auch die Inflationserwartungen zu
dämpfen in der Tat im Euroraum läuft die
Wirtschaft eher schlecht eine Aktion
bahnt sich an da sind steigende Zinsen
eigentlich Gift doch die EZB hat wohl
keine Wahl
wenn sie aus falscher Rücksicht auf die
Konjunktur jetzt die Zinsen nicht weiter
kräftig anheben würde dann wird das
inflationsproblem in der Zukunft nur
noch größer was dann noch mehr
Zinsanhebung erfordern würde wo runter
die Konjunktur am Ende noch stärker
leiden würde klar ist aber auch die EZB
wird nicht ewig weiter an der
Zinsschraube drehen können die EZB wird
nicht wenn wir dann mitten in der
Rezession sind weitermachen mit
Zinsschritten das heißt die muss jetzt
versuchen so schnell wie möglich auf in
einigermaßen neutrales normales
Zinsniveau zu bekommen und ich denke das
spätestens im Februar nächsten Jahres
auch Ende und Schluss sein wird mit den
Zinserhöhungen
vorerst aber geraten die Baubranche und
andere Wirtschaftszweig in eine
schwierige Lage weil die Bekämpfung der
Inflation zusammenfällt mit der
erwarteten Rezession nicht wenige meinen
die EZB haben mit ihren Zinsschritten
einfach zu lange gewartet
und wir fragen auch hier noch mal nach
bei unserem Mann an der Frankfurter
Börse Frank Bethmann Frank werms gerade
gehört die Zinserhöhung verpuffe weil
sie zu spät komme stimmt das naja sie
ist durchaus so spät gekommen aber sie
ist auch wohlwollend aufgenommen worden
man muss allerdings auch sagen alles
andere als diese zweite
aufeinanderfolgende xxl-erhöhung von
0,75% Punkten wäre die eigentliche
Überraschung gewesen die Märkte haben
mit diesem Zinsschritt auch in dieser
Höhe gerechnet zu sehr ist die Teuerung
bereits davongelaufen zu sehr ist die
EZB bereits ins Hintertreffen geraten
viel zu spät wir haben es gehört hat sie
die Zinswende eingeleitet deswegen Sie
nun die schlagzeil weiter hochhalten
muss dass heute wird auch nicht die
letzte Zinsanhebung für dieses Jahr
gewesen sein wobei mit sinkenden Preisen
voraussichtlich tatsächlich erst im
Frühjahr zu rechnen sein wird Kritiker
dieser Entscheidung führen ja auch an
dass die Inflation von den hohen
Energiepreisen angetrieben wird gegen
die man mit höheren Zinsen eigentlich
gar nichts machen kann sondern die Lage
eher kümmert wie stichhaltig ist das ja
das stimmt die hohen Energiepreise ist
nicht etwas was man mit Leitzinsen
bekämpfen kann ebenso wenig kann man die
gestörten Lieferketten wieder reparieren
mit hohen Leitzinsen aber wir haben das
ja eben gesehen die Zinsen sie führen
dazu dass die Zinsen auch am Markt
hochgehen wer jetzt noch kein Haus
gebaut hat oder gekauft hat der wird
künftig immer tiefer in die Tasche
greifen müssen gerade für viele Familien
ist der Traum vom Eigenheim ausgeträumt
auch Verbraucherkredite werden sich
weiter verteilen andererseits gibt es
wieder erste Zinsen auf den Tages- und
Festgeld konnten die allerdings
verglichen mit der Inflationsrate von
derzeit zehn Prozent verschwindend
gering sind steigen sie Zinsen sind
zudem Gift für eine Wirtschaft die
ohnehin mit Krieg und unsicheren
Geschäftserwartungen zu kämpfen hat doch
spätestens seit der Tagung von IWF und
Weltbank vor zwei Wochen ist klar die
Bekämpfung der Inflation hat jetzt
Vorrang selbst wenn die Wirtschaft dabei
vorübergehend Schaden nimmt frank
beetmann war das vielen Dank für die
Einordnung von der Frankfurter Börse
und wir machen weiter mit Gundula und
den Nachrichten und die beginnen mit der
Ursache für die hohen Energiepreise
nämlich dem Krieg in der Ukraine im
Süden der Ukraine verschärfen sich die
Kämpfe zur Befreiung der russisch
besetzten und annektierten Stadt
Croissant offenbar gelingt es den
ukrainischen Truppen nicht so zügig wie
erhofft die strategisch wichtige Stadt
zurückzuerobern währenddessen setzen die
russischen Streitkräfte ihre Angriffe in
der ganzen Ukraine massiv fort wie hier
in bachmut wurden Wohnhäuser und
kritische
Infrastruktureinrichtungen beschädigt
viele Orts gibt es keinen Strom
erneuert hat russlands Präsident Putin
den Westen für die Zuspitzung der Lage
in der Ukraine verantwortlich gemacht
früher oder später werde der Westen aber
mit Russland über eine gemeinsame
Zukunft sprechen müssen sagte er auf
einer Konferenz vor internationalen
politik-experten er erklärte zudem
Russland haben nicht die Absicht in der
Ukraine Atomwaffen einzusetzen
außerdem hat der russische Präsident
angekündigt die Zusammenarbeit mit Iran
zu verstärken dabei gehe es ihm um die
abwehrterroristischer Bedrohungen so
Putin in einem Telegramm an
iranspräsidenten reisi darin sprach er
der Führung in Teheran sein Beileid
wegen des Anschlags in Shiraz aus in
einer schiitischen Moschee haben
Angreifer 15 Menschen getötet die
sunnitische terrormiliz islamischer
Staat reklamierte den Anschlag für sich
nach jahrzehntelangem Streit haben
Israel und der Libanon ein Abkommen über
die gemeinsame Seegrenze im Mittelmeer
unterzeichnet formell befinden sich die
beiden Länder seit 2006 im Krieg in
Jerusalem unterschrieb Israels premier
Lapid in Beirut Libanon Staatschef aun
die USA hatten das Grenzabkommen
vermittelt und damit die Nutzungsrechte
für die zwei Gasfelder in dem
umstrittenen Gebiet vor der gemeinsamen
Küste
eine halbe Stunde Akropolis ein paar
Bilder der Harmonie mit dem griechischen
Ministerpräsidenten mitsotakis Olaf
Scholz war heute zu Gast in Athen doch
das Terrain ist schwierig Griechenland
wünscht sich die aktive re Unterstützung
Deutschlands im Dauerkonflikt mit der
Türkei die beiden Nato-Partner streiten
über Inseln in der Ägäis über
Flüchtlinge und immer wieder provoziert
der türkische Präsident Erdogan die
Griechen mit der Erkundung von
Gasvorkommen im Mittelmeer Scholz
stellte sich an die Seite Griechenlands
versuchte aber gleichzeitig die Türkei
nicht zu sehr zu verärgern Andreas
Kühnast hat den Kanzler nach Athen
begleitet
das ist der Vorteil wenn man
Bundeskanzler ist dass man nicht über
staub- oder Laub laufen muss nicht
anstehen muss und nicht allein klettern
muss auf den berühmtesten Berg
Griechenlands der Reiseleiter ist der
Ministerpräsident der Regierungssprecher
der außenpolitikberater und der
Wirtschaftspolitik Berater kraxeln
hinterher das Kyriakos mit sotakis Olaf
Scholz auf die Akropolis geschleppt hat
ist durchaus als Wink gemeint an die
Deutschen die die Griechen so gern und
so häufig belehren
hier wurde die Demokratie geboren hier
ist einer der Höhepunkte die griechische
Kultur dem Rest der Welt zu bieten hat
ich glaube das hat dem Kanzler sehr
gefallen
dass das Verhältnis zwischen Athen und
Berlin nicht mehr das zwischen schwach
und stark ist nicht mehr das zwischen
Kreditnehmer und Kreditgeber wird mit so
Tages heute mehrmals betonen
Teufel war nie auf der Akropolis
es ist der Nachteil wenn man
Bundeskanzler ist dass man für alles
Deutsche verantwortlich gemacht wird
deutsche Panzer bleiben Scholz Panzer
auch wenn sie inzwischen den Griechen
gehören mitten in den aufgeheizten
Grenzstreit mit der Türkei hinein
verlegt Griechenland diese sechs
Schützenpanzer Marder die es vergangene
Woche aus Deutschland erhalten hat
Griechenland wehrt sich gegen
Forderungen der Türkei sein Militär von
seinen Mittelmeerinseln abzuziehen
unsere Nachbarn wissen es alle anderen
wissen es die griechischen Inseln sind
keine Gefahr wir sind keine Gefahr
so defensiv hatte es der türkische
Präsident nicht formuliert wir können
eines Nachts ganz plötzlich kommen
Scholz kritisiert die militärischen
Drohungen verweist auf das Völkerrecht
bietet Vermittlung an dabei versucht er
größtmöglichen Abstand zu den Panzern
deutscher Herkunft zu gewinnen die
türkische Regierung ist bereits außer
sich seit Satellitenbilder eine
Verlegung amerikanischer Typen an
griechische Küsten zeigen
wir haben wenn ich das zunächst sagen
darf die
Marder geliefert an Griechenland und da
gibt es keine tägliche Meldung wo die
gerade stehen wir fragen auch nicht nach
das haben wir mit all den Waffen die wir
in den letzten Jahren geliefert haben
auch nicht gemacht und das werden wir
auch in Zukunft nicht tun nichts
ausrichten konnte Scholz gegen die
Reparationsforderungen die Athen auch
heute gegen Deutschland erhob das ist
nicht persönlich gemeint aber bitter
ernst das ist der Nachteil wenn man
Bundeskanzler ist
wir wissen es alle längst wir müssen uns
mehr anstrengen um die weitere Erwärmung
des Klimas zu begrenzen weg von fossilen
Brennstoffen hin zu erneuerbaren wer
jetzt schon eine Heizung hat die
Holzpellets verbrennt hat das Gefühl auf
dem richtigen Weg zu sein gelten Pellets
doch als sauberer und eben
nachwachsender Rohstoff das aber stimmt
nur wenn die gepressten Stäbchen nicht
aus Holz hergestellt sind dass durch
industriellen Kahlschlag ganzer Wälder
gewonnen wird da die Pellets aber gerade
hoch begehrt und schwer nachgefragt sind
geschieht genau das die Abholzung
riesiger wertvoller Waldgebiete Wolf
Christian Ulrich berichtet aus Rumänien
unterwegs in einem eu-weltschutzgebiet
in den Karpaten was die Umweltschützer
von Greenpeace hier vorfinden sieht aber
nicht nach Schutzgebiet aus sondern nach
Kahlschlag
120 Jahre alt er wurde
höchstwahrscheinlich gefällt um daraus
Holzpellets zu machen
Holzpellets die auch in deutschen
wohnzimmernern verbrannt werden während
hier die blanken Stümpfe zurückbleiben
karlschlag im Schutzgebiet sei erlaubt
argumentieren Holzindustrie und
Regierung wenn die Bäume stürmen und
Käfern zum Opfer gefallen sein doch der
Augenschein zeigt hier Kahlschlag in
einem gesunden Wald
wir fahren dahin wo die Bäume aus dem
Schutzgebiet zu holzpellets werden gut
zu erkennen wie man ganze Stämme hier in
einem großen Häcksler lädt und zu
spähnen zerkleinert
meistens dass die Hersteller Säge mehr
und Äste zu Pellets verarbeiten aber man
kann hier gut sehen dass sie ganze Bäume
nehmen
die Umweltschützer rechnen vor dass 40%
der rumänischen holzverträge aus
Schutzgebieten stammen die EU fordert
von den rumänischen Behörden das
Holzfällen streng zu kontrollieren doch
der waldnutzungsplan für dieses
Schutzgebiet sieht gar keine Kontrollen
vor ein Sprecher des Umweltministeriums
meint dazu
was wir in dieser Diskussion mit
bedenken müssen 3 Millionen Haushalte in
Rumänien heizen noch mit Holz
weil die rumänische Regierung die
eu-weltschutzgebiete nicht ausreichend
schützt läuft ein
Vertragsverletzungsverfahren bisher ohne
Ergebnis
holzverheizen oder Schutz der Wälder was
hat Priorität fragen wir den
Umweltkommissar der EU überraschende
Antwort
first das wichtigste ist das Heizen und
Brennstoff für die Europäer und dann auf
lange Sicht müssen wir unseren Pflichten
der Umwelt gegenüber Nachkommen
die eu-subventioniert das Holz verheizen
mit Milliarden gleichzeitig gelten diese
kahlschlagflächen in den Statistiken als
CO2-Speicher obwohl der teilweise gar
kein Baum mehr steht
wo mehr Teig es dauert jetzt hundert
Jahre bis wieder so viel CO2 gespeichert
ist wie als der Wald noch stand was das
mit Klimaschutz zu tun haben soll ist
mir schleierhaft
activity in der EU werden weltweit die
meisten Holzpellets verbraucht der denns
steigend mit milliardensubventioniert in
Zeiten der Energiekrise wenig Hoffnung
für Wald und Klima
und jetzt gibt es noch mal Nachrichten
mit Gundula und wir bleiben beim Thema
Klimaschutz ja künftig sollen in der EU
nur noch klimaneutrale Neuwagen verkauft
werden die im Betrieb keine
Treibhausgase ausstoßen diese Regelung
soll 2035 in Kraft treten darauf haben
sich Unterhändler der EU-Staaten und des
Europaparlaments geeinigt wie die
tschechische Ratspräsidentschaft gerade
eben mitteilte im Jahr 2026 solle die
Entscheidung erneut überprüft werden
können
der Star Koch Alfons Schuhbeck ist von
Münchner Landgericht zu einer Haftstrafe
von drei Jahren und zwei Monaten ohne
Bewährung verurteilt worden der
73-Jährige hatte gestanden über Jahre
2,3 Millionen Euro an Steuern
hinterzogen zu haben dazu hatte er ein
Computerprogramm schreiben lassen um
unerkannt die Kassen seiner beiden
Münchner Restaurants manipulieren zu
können
ein Ergebnis vom Fußball in der Europa
League hat der 1 fC Union Berlin aktuell
Bundesliga Tabellen erster zu Hause
gegen Sporting Braga aus Portugal
gewonnen mit 1:0 damit stehen die
Chancen gut für den Einzug in die
k.o.-phase
neuer Trainer bei Schalke 04 wird Thomas
Reis der 49-Jährige tritt die Nachfolge
des entlassenen Frank Kramer an und soll
den Tabellen letzten vor dem Abstieg
retten zuvor war Reis beim VfL Bochum
und hatte mit dem Reviernachbarn den
Klassenerhalt überraschend geschafft
Reis ist bereits der siebte Trainer auf
Schalke in nur zwei Jahren
die alljährliche Abstimmung Vogel des
Jahres hat diesmal das Braunkehlchen
gewonnen mit dieser Wahl des
Naturschutzbundes NABU lenken
Vogelfreunde die Aufmerksamkeit auf eine
gefährdete Tierart in Deutschland gibt
es noch höchstens 35.000 braun Kirchen
Paare Tendenz stark fallend weil es
immer weniger artenreiche Wiesen und
Blühstreifen gibt
Susanna ist eine attraktive junge Frau
so schön dass zwei ältere Männer die
sich für unwiderstehlich halten sie zum
Sex zwingen wollen Susanna sagt nein
worauf die Abgewiesenen sie unter einem
Vorwand vor Gerichtsherren die
Geschichte stammt aus dem Alten
Testament und zeugt davon dass das Thema
von Machtmissbrauch und sexueller Gewalt
ein ewiges ist
dieser Erkenntnis folgend hat das Kölner
Wallraf Richards Museum eine Ausstellung
konzipiert die sich mit den
Darstellungen der Szene von Susanna im
Bade beschäftigt vom Mittelalter bis
Mito mal ist Susanna eine keusche Heldin
mal wert sie sich Lothar Becker hat die
Ausstellung in Köln gesehen
das Wallraf richartz-museum lässt auf
einmalige Art eintauchen in die Welt der
Susanna der biblischen Figur die wir
keine zweite in der Kunstwelt über
Jahrhunderte zum Sinnbild sexueller
Nötigung wurde aber eben auch zum
Sinnbild der Tugend weil sie obwohl mit
dem Tode bedroht die beiden alten Männer
zurückwies
im Hintergrund von me too ist es
natürlich noch mal eine ganz andere
Befremdung die wir feststellen es ist
hat grausame Aktualität das Thema bis
heute und es ist sicherlich auch so dass
diese Darstellungen diese gehäuften
Darstellungen von sexualisierter Gewalt
traumatische Erinnerungen wecken können
das ist uns durchaus bewusst aber wir
haben uns entschieden sie zu zeigen das
Thema nicht verschweigen die Bilder
nicht ins depotverband Wissen sondern
damit Anlass geben zu Diskussion Ziel
der Kölner Ausstellung thematisch
sortiert versammelt sie vom Mittelalter
bis heute Kunstwerke aus der ganzen Welt
die allermeisten verbindet über
Jahrhunderte Kunstgeschichte die Wahl
des einen Motivs Susanna nackt
diese nacktheit ist kein Selbstzweck ich
glaube das kann man wenn man diese
Ausstellung durchschritten hat
nachvollziehen sie ist erzählt Mittel
beweiskünstlerische Genialität
Sinnlichkeit darzustellen
Aktmalerei gehört zum Handwerk einer
jeden Künstlerin eines jeden Künstlers
gerade im 19 Jahrhundert sehen wir
zusammen die eigentlich in einer
atelierpose gezeigt werden verschiedene
Werke schaffen es die Attraktivität der
Susanna zu betonen sie in ihrer
Verletzlichkeit schön und stark zu
zeigen samt ihrer Gegenwehr trotz der
Übermacht der übergriffigen alten es ist
eine Art Schule des Sehens um eben
zu erspüren wo
unterscheiden sich die Künstler welchen
Akzent setzen sie
erwecken sie vielleicht Mitleid für
Susanna wollen Sie unsere Empathie oder
beschuldigen sie uns der das Voyeurismus
der Mittäterschaft wenn Susanna uns
empört aus den Bildern anschaut
Werke im Einzelnen und die Ausstellung
im gesamten konfrontieren die
Besuchenden mit ihrer eigenen
Vorstellung von Moral und ihrem Umgang
mit Machtmissbrauch und sexualisierter
Gewalt die längst nicht nur auf die
Besetzungscouch von Hollywood beschränkt
sondern allgegenwärtig ist
eine Ausstellung nicht nur für Frauen ab
morgen zu sehen im Kölner Wallraf
richards-museum und hier geht es weiter
mit Maybrit Illner sie diskutiert mit
ihren Gästen über Putins neue
terrorstrategie Ukraine zerstören Europa
Spalten das ist die Frage
und um 0 Uhr hat Hanna Zimmermann dann
das heute journal Update für Sie und uns
gibt es morgen wieder einen angenehmen
Abend tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter dieser Oktober
könnte der wärmste seit 1881 werden aber
es ist nicht nur der einzelne Monat
sondern der Trend der zu warmen Monate
so spielt sich die globale Erhitzung im
lokalen wieder aus ja und sie sehen von
Südwesten kommt die warme Luft von
Spanien über Frankreich nach Deutschland
und diese Wetterlage kennen Sie sie
wiederholt sich so gibt es dann 20 bis
25 Grad flächendeckend in Deutschland in
der Nacht in der Südhälfte teils dichter
Nebel ansonsten ganz im Norden etwas
Regen bei dichter Bewölkung ja
dazwischen ist es trocken bei
Temperaturen von 18 Grad im Westen
Deutschlands und sechs Grad im Südosten
und diese nachts diese Nachtkarte könnte
genauso gut eine tagkarte im Oktober
sein so mild ist die Nacht wir schauen
auf den Tag und da gibt es nach
nebelauflös im Süden Sonnenschein
genauso wie im Westen sonst sind die
Wolken teils milchig da strahlt dann die
Sonne durch und die Temperaturen die
steigen auf 27 Grad im Südwesten
Deutschlands 25 Grad Richtung
Niederrhein und immer noch 18 Grad an
der Ostsee diese Karte könnte aus dem
Sommer stammen wir schauen auf die
nächsten Tage und warm geht es weiter 26
Grad am Samstag trocken mit viel
Sonnenschein immer noch warm am Sonntag
bis 25 und nur ein bisschen weniger mit
16 bis 23 Grad am Montag ein schöner
Abend